[Music]
so
and welcome to our second panel of the
day green business practice how business
can achieve
net zero the government will be looking
for the private sector to reduce its
emissions in the years to come
what does it really mean for a business
to achieve net zero
should companies and their sectors
account for only their direct emissions
or must they also measure their indirect
impact
related to supply chain or digital
carbon footprints
how should businesses address their
historic emissions and what might this
mean for a once carbon intensive
sector joining me to discuss all this
and more
is tom delay chief chief executive of
the carbon trust
scott leader market director at velux
and chris stark
chief executive of the climate change
committee welcome to you all and a big
thank you to vlux for sponsoring this
panel
now for viewers at home we want to take
your questions i'm going to put them to
the panel over the next hour
you can submit them by typing in the
text box on spectator tv
or by emailing events spectator dot co
dot uk so we're going to hear a few
minutes of opening remarks from each of
our panelists
i'll abuse my position as chair for a
few minutes with some questions and then
we'll get straight
to yours so tom why don't you kick us
off
okay let's just look at net zero um it's
an enormously
challenging aim it's many decades out in
most cases
and what it means is that
the economies of the whole globally need
to reduce their carbon emissions
very significantly on a pathway to the
point at which they've reached virtually
nothing
what is left of their emissions which
they cannot reduce it's really the
absolute minimum
they then have to find a way of
offsetting using greenhouse gas removal
that's not just a straightforward carbon
offset
it's actually taking carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere
now with every organization in every
country
reduces and achieves net zero we will
globally have achieved net zero
there are some points i've raised very
quickly firstly net zero there is no
single definition for what net zero
means
and that does create a number of
challenges
you can have net zero on a geographic
basis so the uk can have a net zero
target
for a geographic view of the the country
most organizations have a value chain
that often goes internationally
from maybe the raw materials to the
manufacturing to the distribution and
finally the use
so net zero can be a longer value chain
it can also be by
geography it's enormously challenging
for most organizations really they have
to say look
two things one we need to measure our
carbon emissions those that we are
directly responsible for
those are called scope one and two we
also need to measure and understand
and take account of scope 3 emissions
which is everything upstream of us as an
organization
and everything downstream through to the
consumer and in fact recycling and waste
and so on
so it's a very expansive view of what
you have to measure as your carbon
emissions
for most organizations that means in the
short term optimizing what you do
finding ways of being more efficient
using less emitting less
as you go forward if you're really going
to gradually bring down your
carbon emissions to zero you've actually
got to do more than simply optimize
today
you've actually got to transform your
business at some point you've got to
make some structural changes in almost
every case
to fundamentally change the nature of
the business but that's being driven
along with the rest of society over a
number of decades
so that really is the challenge it's an
enormously difficult one
and before we forget at today's global
economy
is about half of what the global economy
will be in about 2050
that's just given economic growth that
we're going to see coming through
with a particularly strong growth in
southeast asia
and infrastructure so not only are we
trying to reduce what we have
today to nothing we're trying to reduce
something that's going to be a lot
bigger
to nothing so businesses have an
absolutely key role to play
uh there are many many leaders around
the world in
many different sectors many of them here
in the uk
we work with over 100 organizations at
the moment on helping them understand
what
xero means for them developing pathways
underpinning the claims that they've
already made and maybe deciding what
targets are appropriate for them
it's fascinating because working across
different sectors with different kinds
of organizations
everyone has unique challenges and to
some degree
i think if nothing else it'd be great
this morning just to understand
the scope and the boundary of some of
those challenges and how different
people are facing those
that's probably enough from me to start
with well thank you so much
uh over to you scott uh thanks kate
um i work for velux and those of you are
not familiar
were an international business
established in denmark in 1941
and we employ over 10 000 people across
35 countries
and we manufacture roof windows and roof
lights
i'm really happy to be here today to try
and share some of
the vision that v lux have on this topic
um
and hope that we can inspire others and
and have people have some interest in
that
plus also we've got some good expertise
on the panel and to listen to
to their experts expert opinion um
on this and from our foundation we're
built on
sustainability we're built on daylight
and fresh air and energy efficiency
however what we need to do is look at
how we manufacture
and so does the rest of of the business
world um
too and why are we looking at this um
quite simply because the world needs it
um
i think the un calls the 2020s the
decade of action
when it comes to climate change and
everyone needs to play their part
and business plays a big part um in that
so
last september felux launched a
commitment as part of the r2030
sustainability strategy
which we actually call our nature and
it's to half the carbon used in our
products
and to become a carbon neutral company
and this is crucial because we work in
the construction sector
which contributes eleven percent of the
world's carbon emissions in terms of
component manufacturing and construction
of buildings and that's what's called
embodied carbon uh but also there's
there's emissions that we're more
familiar with which is a
building's lifetime emission which is
around an additional 28
so that's almost 30 or 39 to 40 percent
of the greenhouse emissions which
construction is inc accountable for
which shows that our industry really
needs to step up and and make an impact
here
and if we're again looking into the
future because that that's today
but if we look into the future we also
know that the global re
real estate um is going to close to
double
up to 200 2060 um and as an industry we
pretty much build paris every single
week so it's a really important part to
our future to make sure that we're
that we're working hard here now
we know that this is not easy and the
task that we're setting ourselves is
difficult
and we're under no illusions about how
challenging it will be
and we also don't have all the answers
yet but what we need to do is work
together with all of our partners
and collaborate internally to make sure
that we can we can meet where we want to
be
so we look at our internal business
practices and we want to be a carbon
neutral
company in our production by 2030
but we also need to look at our supply
chain scope free which was discussed a
second ago
um and what we're looking to do there is
to reduce the carbon content in our in
our product by 50
by 2030 so if you buy the equivalent
product in 2030 compared to now
then that would have 50 less carbon um
content
and then just finally we're also as well
as looking at future emissions we're
also
looking looking back in the past so our
sustainability strategy has 15 strands
to it
and one other i just want to briefly
mention is our
our plan to become lifetime carbon
neutral by 2041 which will be our 100th
year
anniversary because we feel it's also
important to address
future as well as repay the historic
carbon debt
um and we're working with the world
wildlife fund on this
to undertake a series of reforestation
and conservation projects
um around the world i think that's it
from me
thank you thanks very much scott over to
you chris
thanks kate and thanks to tom and scott
as well so i just i thought it might be
worth just kind of
stepping back a bit and ask and asking a
couple of questions about
what we actually need to do to get to
net zero because it involves a lot of
things happening
uh in unison and it's worth just
thinking for a second about why we're
doing all this i mean the the reason
that
we have this problem is is is because we
are using assets
at the moment technologies at the moment
that burn fossil fuels
so if we want to get to net zero we need
to swap those assets this is the cars
that we drive the boilers the vans the
plant machining that we use in industry
for zero carbon
versions of those assets so actually i
think it's worth
starting with that challenge that it is
a an asset turnover challenge
an investment challenge that um that
faces us here in the uk and around the
world
in getting to net zero there's a bit
more to it than that but that is a large
part of of what needs to be done
and and i think that's at the heart of
why these corporate commitments to net
zero are so important
so we just look at that for a second the
average life of a capital asset that
uses fossil fuels
today if you bought something new is 15
to 20 years
so something bought today is likely to
still be in use
by 2040. so that's the challenge
if we want to get to net zero by
mid-century
and if we want that transition to be
well-managed inexpensive
uh with the the minimum of disruption
then what we need is a plan
that turns over those capital assets
from high carbon versions to zero carbon
versions
as quickly as possible but also in as a
well-managed way as possible
and if we think in that way about it you
can ask lots of interesting questions
then about how to do that
what's the appropriate policy to do that
what role might industry have in that
what role might the consumer have in it
we estimate that that investment
challenge
is about an extra 50 billion pounds of
capital investment each year for the
for the uk economy and that is a big
number
that's adding an eighth overall to the
capex in the uk economy
um and that needs to be the number that
we get to by about 2030
so from 2030 onwards that kind of
investment challenge
is what is is it will get us to net zero
getting to that kind of that kind of
level of investment overall
and 2030 is really the key date because
if we're ready by 2030
to stop selling and installing those
high carbon assets
and moving now exclusively to zero
carbon assets then we'll make it on time
and so that kind of period that decade
that um that's got talked about is
absolutely right this is the decade of
action because we need to get to the
point by 2030 when we're ready to
uh to to replace an earnest those assets
that we that we buy and use and those
technologies that we use at the moment
so the corporate plans for net zero are
absolutely critical for that
i would love to see this taken more
seriously in boardrooms not just a csr
thing
but a genuinely meaningful strand to
corporate strategies we need businesses
to invest
we need don't need them also to take
account of the emissions that they are
responsible for
for many businesses that is going to be
a fundamental shift
the logic of this is that businesses
themselves need to make the transition
not they are you know put out a business
or that they have to you know they're
that they face difficulties but actually
they go along with this and then come
out at the end of it in a decarbonized
way
fit for the kind of modern economy so
it's tempting to think of all this as a
policy challenge but it really isn't of
course
it's it's about a number of parties
including our corporate community
going along with that broadly we see the
government's role as providing the
framework for all of this
so providing the policies uh the the
right incentives the support
uh with public money where we're
necessary to make the kind of transition
that we've just talked about
and then business is there the private
sector is what drives the transition
so it's it's the carbonizing operations
that it's responsible for directly
especially by moving
for example vehicle fleets to electric
vehicles that kind of thing it's about
fostering the innovation that we'll need
for all this as well
especially using procurement to drive
down emissions um
a whole set of things also that can
nudge the customers of our corporates
uh towards low-carbon choices too and
and the key thing in all of this
is that the businesses commitments need
to be aligned with the
pathway that the country is on not
actually that not so much that the
businesses sign up to net zero
themselves but they are aligned with the
changes that the whole economy needs to
make
to get to net zero and and there's a set
of things you can do that but it starts
with doing the basics
measuring your emissions disclosing them
targeting action in the
in your own company in the right way
then adopting
the highest possible ambition that you
can for cutting emissions
uh in the business and if possible even
going beyond
scope three which might seem an
interesting and a difficult
thing to do but in particular driving
the the the transition that we need
across the uk
yourself with the corporate commitments
that you can make
for example leading that transition to
electric vehicles in the uk switching
vehicle fleets
over to electric vehicles before the the
kind of deadlines that the country is
making
yeah using corporate renewable
procurement to establish
new uh uh solar and
and and wind uh installations in the uk
to help the country make that transition
to
that's the kind of secret here in
getting to net zero quickly
and it won't happen of course unless
climate change is an issue is sitting
at the top the top level of corporate
leadership being discussed
uh at board level uh in an active way
so it's a i mean we're at the start of
this journey now and it's just it's just
really exciting to think that way
thanks chris uh we already have
questions rolling in which is fantastic
a reminder to our watchers at home
uh or or in your office uh is that if
you would like to submit a question
you can do so via the text box on
spectator tv
or you can email events at spectator dot
co dot uk
um but just to throw a few questions out
there first tom you mentioned in your
opening remarks that there were
differing definitions um when it comes
to net zero
how well do you think businesses
understand exactly
what net zero or even those different
definitions
mean particularly when it comes to
things like supply chains and
indirect emissions do you think
businesses have the awareness to know
that it isn't just about their direct
emissions but it's about their their
wider
reaching impact on the climate i think
most businesses nowadays
want to align themselves with best
practice and there is best practice
definition for net zero that applies for
the vast majority of sectors and
therefore organizations
wherever you are in the world and that
is to
set a pathway to reduce your carbon
emissions through a science-based target
out to 2050 maybe earlier than that
follow that science-based target now the
science-based target approach
requires you to look at both your own
director missions scope 1
2 and also your upstream and downstream
emissions scope three
um the majority of organizations the
minute they start
looking internet zero realize that that
is best practice
in many cases they focus on the short
term which has a great deal of value to
it because actually getting going is
often the most difficult thing
measuring setting targets doing those
early steps to optimize your current
business
and to some degree they need to develop
options for the future
yes the majority of organizations do
understand that it's not just scope one
into its scope three
those who to some degree resist it in
some cases it's because they find it
very hard to see how they can influence
scope three
the reality is that virtually every
organization can influence scope 3 and
has to
um i think the point was well made you
know we are basically using
natural resources in a very inefficient
way today
we developed today's economy at a time
when natural resources including
you know don't say the atmosphere um
that we enjoy um was abundant it was
cheap
if we didn't look at the materials use
of the energy use you just assumed it
was all going to be available
if you were to redefine today's economy
to meet the needs that we all have
as citizens as consumers and as
businesses
you do it in a far more efficient way
because you'd be aware of the cost of
some of the things that you're using
in a pretty wasteful way so
start from there there is enormous
opportunity in almost every
organization the vast majority of
businesses we work with will work to
best practice which is a science-based
target
leading to net zero at some point in
future
for those who can't at the moment do
that there are a number of different
proxies and i like chris's point about
it's contributing to net zero globally
that is almost as important as doing it
yourself
um that is important there are
organizations that are going to struggle
to get to net zero and shrink because
they are actually growing
a wind turbine manufacturer and yet we
want more wind turbines
and so at that point you've got to look
at exactly what works carbon neutrality
is a very useful measure as well
if you are carbon neutral and you
continue to be carbon neutral then
eventually you will move towards net
zero
um but um i i would say yes there is
best practice the definitions
aren't uh singular people will use that
sometimes as a
hang on is this for a country for a city
for a state for a company
it doesn't really matter get into it and
it's fairly straightforward and the vast
majority of businesses not just very
large businesses
but increasingly smaller businesses that
have a particular drive to do this and
can come from their investors from their
employees or from their consumers
the information is widely available
chris a recent report from the climate
change committee found that government
was not on track to be meeting its
targets and to be achieving net zero
that was the assessment of government
policy and
with where they're at in this journey
what's your broader sense
assessment of business are the right
policies being implemented in the
private sector
to get us to the targets that we've set
yeah that's a really interesting
question and important to say that you
know it's not our role to make an
assessment of the progress that the
business community is making on net zero
i mean i suppose
the answer to your question
straightforwardly is no they're not
doing enough because then
no one is so that there's a kind of
collective need to raise the ambition
and to actually deliver against that the
the signs and the targets that have been
set in the uk
but i i was a bit of nuance to that is
that um
we are seeing now much more of a
corporate drive
towards tackling net zero uh and even
the broader discussion of
of the impact of the corporate community
on the environment and that is that is a
new thing i think
and there's a couple of things behind
that i mean it's definitely the case
that larger corporates in the uk are
are now much more focused on net zero as
a topic than they ever were before and
that's really happened in the last
couple of years
some of what's driving that of course is
that you know the social awareness of
the issues
uh the general drive towards net zero
which corporate community are picking up
on and acting on but a part of it is
also being driven by
the need to actively think about it and
to disclose some of the risks that are
faced by the corporate community so
we have this new set of financial
disclosure rules the tcfd rules
um which are going to be mandatory
at some stage and and and drive i think
a much
better and really useful understanding
of the extent to which
a business is exposed to climate change
itself
so thinking in particular about
financial institutions here
whose assets will be damaged and
impacted by the change in the climate
that's coming
but also and i think much more
intriguingly for this discussion
that the transition risk that is how
exposed is that business
how exposed are the assets of that
business to
that to the move from where we are today
to zero carbon itself
and i think that is that's great from my
perspective because it's driving a much
better sense of the realistic
economics here the kind of the need to
be commercially aware of those risks
which is in turn driving a a move
towards what we can actually do about it
and the need to act on it
so back to my other point getting to net
zero
involves a lot of things happening at
once
it's often the case that we point to the
government as being you know the primary
actors here and i do think it's
important that governments
around the world lead a lot of this but
it is not the case that government is
solely responsible for
the actions that will need to take place
in fact it's much more about the
government
shaping those actions in the real
economy and
that will happen if if we have a unison
between the policies that government
make
uh the targets of course that government
has set and then you know the
the willingness of of our corporate
community especially to drive that and
to make the investments i talked about
earlier now i think a lot of that to be
positive for a second
is now moving in the right direction we
were critical of the government
last week but we did that in the
knowledge that there is a space for them
to address our concerns over the next uh
weeks months weeks and months
prior to cop26 if we if that happens if
we have a national strategy for net zero
which we don't have at the moment
then i think it will be very clear what
what the role of the corporate community
can be on that transition and i expect
things to move much more quickly after
that
scott we've seen a rise in shareholders
demanding companies get tougher on their
emissions do you think that drive from
shareholders is making a big difference
i think the drive is from everywhere um
not just from shared
shareholders also from the market it's
also from consumers
um i read a report last week that a lot
of consumers think that they're doing
the best they can
and now they need business to to take
this on
so of course from the top with the
shareholders pushing this down there's
something that's really important
to business that will help but i think
the drive is actually from the whole
community
and the whole market in general
um tom we have a question from jane
asking about the infrastructure that's
going to need to be in place by
2030 2040 before these net zero
aspirations
to come to life now the government is
inevitably going to have some role to
play in that but when we're talking
about electric vehicles for example the
private sector
has a big role to play as well do you
think they're up to the challenge
um absolutely they're up to the
challenge i mean the heavy lifting
in any transformation to net zero uh
developing low carbon products and
services of the future is going to be
done by the private sector
government can shape the environment in
which people can invest to achieve that
outcome
but it's going to be the private sector
that's going to do the heavy lifting and
is absolutely up for this and i think
the reasons uh
let's go back very briefly um five years
ago we had a paris agreement
that was terrific in that it actually
brought together
governments corporates and financial
institutions with a common name
that common aim and alignment uh has
been incredibly powerful over the last
few years and gradually
governments have come together around
the world now there are really very few
governments who are outliers to the
paris agreement and what it means in
terms of bringing everybody together
that's important because many businesses
are global businesses
and they actually need to see a global
response from government to allow them
to get on with the investment they need
to make
the next thing we saw was greta who came
along and quietly but very efficiently
told the world that there is a
generational issue here and that
the voters of the future the consumers
of the future dare i say the savers of
the future
are very much aligned the need to
address the
environment's challenges and become net
zero and lastly covid
most of us looked at covid and went is
this going to be a setback
or is this going to be a step forward
most people would have guessed a step
back
in practice it's a step forward in terms
of momentum for a number of reasons
people feel more closely aligned to the
natural environment at the moment
people recognize that this is no longer
a nice to have it's a must-have
and lastly and most importantly people
are looking now to governments to
stimulate
economic growth and you might as well do
economic growth with a purpose and there
is no better purpose than
achieving this so the private sector are
absolutely up for this and i'm just
going to come back to the financial side
you know there was a time not so long
ago when investors would simply look at
financial returns
it's becoming increasingly clear that
financial returns are under risk if you
don't embrace
and understand what you're investing in
from an environmental perspective
you're now getting to the point where
the cost of capital is higher
for organizations who don't embrace net
zero and don't move the right direction
it's something called cost of capital
drag so basically your business is going
to become more expensive to run
if you don't move along with everybody
else in this direction of travel
so it's it's an incredibly powerful tool
now combination as scott was saying of
consumers increasingly asking for it
um investors demanding it dare i say it
employees of almost every organization
that we work with saying
this is something we care about it
brings everything together
so yeah businesses are absolutely up for
it in virtually every sector
the most heavily carbon intensive
sectors are the ones we need to focus on
because they have real challenges
in some cases there is no transformation
that they can make
without completely reinventing their
business model
chris we have quite a few questions
coming in about technology and the
reliance on
technology to get to net zero that may
not exist yet i think this ties into
jane's infrastructure question about
things that are going to be needed in
the future that we simply
don't have yet how difficult is it to
legislate or come up with public policy
to meet this target when we are talking
about things that simply haven't been
developed yet
well i would challenge that actually the
premise of that altogether i mean
there are several things that we don't
have operating at scale at the moment in
the uk economy that will that we will
need to get to net zero but
we when in designing the a plan for net
zero or at least
an outline of a plan for net zero we set
ourselves the task
of ensuring that we could get to net
zero using technologies that we
already knew would work or were aware of
and and the the 2019 work that led to
the setting of the net zero target for
the uk
was based only on those technologies now
important to say that
there will be new technologies that will
come along they will help us on the way
and i hope that will help us get to net
zero even faster
but we don't need to rely on things that
haven't yet been invented to get to net
zero and that's quite
a reassuring thing because it means that
we can start to plan in earnest
for a transition over the next 20 years
that really does need to take place now
and as those new things come along we
can switch the strategy towards those
uh those technologies that look even
more productive
but let's just look at the kind of
technologies that sit underneath that
the top top top priority for the uk and
it has been the top priority
notably for the last 15 years 20 years
is to decarbonize the electricity system
so going back to your earlier question
to tom about infrastructure
every corporate in the uk should know
that the electricity that
that will be available for that
corporate over the course the next 10 15
years
will eventually get to zero carbon so we
said in our most recent work that by
2035 we should stop burning
unabated fossil fuels to generate
electricity in this country that's the
point where we'll have zero carbon
electricity it's also the point that joe
black
the date that joe biden has set for the
u.s so there's a kind of common view
that really that by around the mid-2030s
electricity will be fully decarbonized
that means that
any industry using that electricity will
be zero carbon
so it's extra it's exciting to think
that way about it because it means that
a lot of that a lot of the hard work is
being done
somewhere else but there are other other
areas where we are going to need to do
more
much more than than just rely on
electricity to get to zero carbon
and and the top of those areas is is
what we call um
greenhouse gas removals and this is
definitely one of the
you know the most controversial topics
when it comes to net zero we know we'll
need to do
some what we would call in the trade
removals to get to net zero that's
because we can't get all emissions to
actual zero especially notably emissions
in farming
uh also probably emissions in aviation
for long long-haul flights it's
difficult to imagine a world where we're
not continuing to use fossil fuels
although there are lots of people who
would like to see that happen it's
unlikely to happen at the pace it needs
to by mid-century
so we need offsets of some type now we
can grow a lot of trees of course
we need to do that in any case but we
also need something over and above that
which is the greenhouse gas removals now
that
there is a collection of technologies
there that will help with that
that will take uh carbon from the from
the air or from the
the the plants that we can grow in this
country and then and then actually
sequester that carbon and put it back
where we
we've had oil and gas deposits those
technologies exist
we know they work we just haven't done
them commercially at scale so i think
those are the things that
need the attention and support of policy
makers and in turn will need the
commercial investment to drive that
but i'm pretty confident we'll have it
and
the uk is one of the best places in the
world to do a lot of this and it's also
you know
we're pretty far down the track of
supporting some of these things too so
i don't regard these as kind of unicorn
technologies really they're there
they will be ready to go as long as the
commercial models are there so i think
other than that
i don't see this big technological gap
that occasionally people
people refer to because i think net zero
itself is driving the kind of innovation
that we need
amongst many of those technologies for
heat for example technologies and
industry towards a more decarbonized
future and the last thing i'll say in
this is that a lot of the technologies
that we will use in our net zero economy
are much much much more efficient so
actually
it's a straightforward simple easy
decision to move from what is quite an
inefficient use of
of fossil fuels to much more efficient
technologies that typically use
electricity
and with that comes the saving so this
investment that i kept i keep talking
about
does have a big payoff once you have
those new
those new zero carbon assets operating
in the business because the operating
costs of those technologies
tends to be much lower than the
alternatives so i'm excited about all
this on a number of grounds but
one of the one of the main grounds for
being excited about this is that it is
it is a step towards a more efficient
economy in the round which of course is
good for us in the long term
scott chris mentioned commercial
investment there
what is the right balance here when it
comes to stumping up the cash
the private sector and if we are going
to be able to pay for this overall is
is going to have to play a large role in
that but i've had several questions
coming in through the text box saying
you know who is going to pay for this is
it going to be the taxpayer is are going
to be
private companies what do you think the
right balance
balances and when it comes to a company
like v lux what are the ethical
responsibilities in the private sector
to help fund all of these changes
yeah it's tricky for me to to understand
what the right balance
would be because it's probably going to
cost everyone
you know a bit as it goes along from a
from a business point of view from v lux
point of view um
we will invest the amount that we need
to to meet our promises
and i think that that significant that's
a significant amount
of money but as i think the other guys
were talking about earlier on
it's something that we have to do it's
something that our
you know the government's doing it's
something that the market demands
something that my children demand as
well by the way um i'm always under
pressure from
from my children about uh sustainability
and the strategy there
so i think the cost is is not
as difficult i think the balance will be
a little bit of everybody
will probably pay a bit of that but in
the long term for business
we have to do this um to keep in
business and to keep growing
as a business
tom we've had a question through uh from
paul asking whether or not net zero is a
useful term especially in the business
community because it can lead
to greenwashing i mean i think we see
this quite frequently actually net zero
has become
uh you know a buzz phrase um it's
something that people love to use to
show or signal that they're
trying to be greener but actually
sometimes it actually ends up meaning
nothing at all when you actually
dig into the content of it so do you
think it's a helpful phrase
or do you think that it's just useful
for pr spin sometimes
um well i hope it's never used for pr
spin
um it it it's because it's a powerful
concept it's a concept that only works
if we all understand it
and stick by the rules as it were um i
think a couple of things firstly
um there are a lot of organizations
who've set net zero targets and
aspirations declared a climate emergency
um frankly without due consideration to
what it really means
um in many cases those organizations are
now having to be more transparent
chris talked about tcfd being a
corporate
submission that is now going to be
expected of holistic companies in the uk
and indeed around the world
similar things are being applied um so
disclosure is going to be required
as a corporate requirement but i think
actually consumers and employees
also expect a great deal of transparency
on this
um you know in most areas of business
life
um you don't share your best secrets
with your competitors
that's all commercially confidential in
the area of environment and
sustainability that's not acceptable
it's not acceptable to anybody to
stakeholders to consumers to your own
employees
so transparency is really important
so um green wash is is a real risk
um i think net zero will be held to
account
by a whole number of people um green
wash we need to be really really careful
of
and the test i use um which is
interesting
is one that a number of analysts have
used looking at different organizations
where they've looked and they said well
that looks like a good plan
yeah that kind of is okay and then they
question the sincerity
and there is a difference between
something which is a plausible plan
where technically all the bits would
hang together but where you just don't
get a sense that the organization has
committed itself
to that future and something where the
organization clearly has got the plan
has got all the targets and the
milestones in place
but is also sincere in its aim now
sincerity is a strange term to use in
business
uh even stranger to use in the world of
finance and yet it is widely being used
at the moment in the world of finance
so yes net zero is crucial
the definition is a very good one we
need to be incredibly careful that green
wash doesn't
take hold of it um and it's up to all of
us
whoever we are wherever we are to call
out
organizations if they cannot support a
net zero claim
by a plausible and a sincere aim to get
that down
over time what do you think chris is net
zero losing its meaning as it's just uh
slapped on as a slogan and uses a pr
stick
i mean i i it's worth saying i do think
that is a risk
because it is only a meaningful concept
if it's being
followed meaningfully just as tom says
i i i suppose this is the this is the
the tension here is that that we have
these corporate commitments for net zero
which are great but actually what we
need is a global commitment to net zero
otherwise that
you know we're going to continue to see
climate changes i mean that's the
science
until we reach net zero emissions
globally we will continue to warm the
planet and continue to cause
climate change now if you're a huge
corporate then
it is a meaningful thing to sign up to
net zero so the likes of i don't know
microsoft's commitment is one of the
better ones i think you know the kind of
really meaningful commitment there
but if if you're a smaller corporate and
that is of course the vast majority of
corporates around the world then
it starts to lose its meaning as a as a
concept in and of itself
hence my point earlier that what really
matters is aligning yourself
in whatever sector you are aligning your
business
with with the plan for net zero for the
uk let's talk about the uk so
that means doing what you can to push
that national plan for net zero along as
quickly as possible
and it raises i suppose the kind of the
other the other
important parts of this discussion which
is that one that we talked
about in my last answer the use of
offsets
um and offsets are useful at the moment
because in many
uh in many sectors it's not possible to
get to zero emissions
and um the use of offsets is is a
meaningful
addition into the strategy but what we
really need to do and
this might sound counter-intuitive is is
to progressively phase out those offsets
and instead focus on on permanent
emission reductions
so that's some of the work that we've
done recently is to look at how quickly
we can do that so
corporates who are using offsets alone
to get to net zero
are not i would say meeting the test
that tom has just told you about
if there is a plan to progressively move
away from using offsets towards actual
emissions reductions and that's the kind
of meaningful plan that will support
the uk strategy for net zero as a whole
and again if we see that kind of move
around the world then we will see
corporates drive the transition to net
zero even more quickly
but that that offsets discussion is i
think one of the critical
things in in the overall plan for net
zero not just here in the uk but around
the world
if it is only achieved uh through the
use of offsets then i don't think net
zero is a meaningful
um a strategy in the round but i i i
sense that that
the the corporate leaders at least are
understanding that more and more now
scott felix is aiming for something
called lifetime
carbon neutral can you tell us more
about that
yep so we're looking back um to 1941
where we started
um as a business to also repay
some of the carbon emission emissions
from the
past um and it's really tricky actually
because there's
there's no particular way of measuring
that so we have worked with
partners to try and put something
together so we can try and
measure that in the right way and get
that into the
into something that we can truly have a
baseline
uh figure and also having auditors
having a look at the calculations to see
where that goes but we we feel that just
doing something
now and in the future was not enough we
also wanted to pay back
um our lifetime carbon emissions too
scott surely that's going to be very
difficult for some of the largest
historic polluters
yeah but i guess i can only look at our
business
um i'm sure that you know that's that's
tricky is tricky for us
as well to actually um really get that
get that right
um we also signed up to the uh
science-based targets initiative um
two as well and we also are being
audited um
on that as well but i think that we
we feel from our business and our sector
that we can do that
um now um and do it in a good way
tom what do you think i mean for some
sectors um it will be an easier job than
others certainly something to applaud
but and
for many the focus is just going to be
on how they can make their business
sustainable in a far more green climate
going forward
you know with very little time at the
moment to really be looking back
yeah i mean i think uh you're quite
right to point out that for some sectors
it's gonna be more difficult than others
um chris mentioned microsoft to some
degree they're the poster child for net
zero
um massive sincerity if you just look at
how they announced the plan with
enormous transparency the leadership of
the company speaking as one off the hymn
sheet
but perhaps more importantly two other
things one to greenhouse gas removals
this
end of the line real moving out
greenhouse gas
is from the atmosphere and sequestering
them um
yes there are lots of nature-based
solutions there are a number of
geological solutions there are also a
number of technologies literally
chemical processes whereby you will
strip
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
they don't really exist at scale today
microsoft came along and said look
it's a core part of our net zero
strategy we're a big organization
they've committed a billion dollars to
research in
exactly that aspect of the end of the
story but they've also said
we will clear our historic debt from
from the outset of microsoft we're going
to do it by 2050.
that's an enormously ambitious thing to
say and and
you've got to congratulate velox for
following pretty much the same logic
but the reality is that they can do it
because their footprint is not that
enormous
so i can think that clearing your
historic debt is something that you can
do in
certain companies in certain sectors it
will be very hard to see an oil and gas
company
able to do that if an oil and gas
company can make
three things happen significantly
enhance and reduce demand for oil and
gas products in the first place
then develop clean energy as a solution
to replace the fossil fuels that are
there
as quickly as you possibly can and
lastly retire the old
as quickly as you can it's all very well
saying we'll do it in 20 years time
if there is a way of replacing the bad
with the good
now do it and retire it for instance
coal
there are a number of mechanisms around
the world being used to financially
incentivize people
to actually retire coal assets early
that's an enormous win for the
atmosphere
it's an enormous win for us all we just
got to make it happen so
i think your points well made i don't
think
every sector is going to be able to
repay its historic debt i think the most
important thing of all
is that we stop using the dirtiest
fossil fuels as quickly as we can
[Music]
just a reminder to our watchers that we
have just over 15 minutes left so if you
do want to submit
any last minute questions please put
them into the text box on spectator tv
or email them to events
at spectator dot co dot uk um chris
i've had a few questions through about
what this is going to cost
to the consumer and it's something that
always comes up when we're talking about
the net zero targets and rightfully so
because people just don't know yet
they haven't been told to what extent
this is really going to cost them and i
don't think they totally believe
certain politicians who come out and say
look you know it won't cost you a penny
this is all going to be
seamless um i thought your report last
week did quite a good job
in highlighting um some of those tougher
trade-offs that we're going to have to
talk about eventually especially when it
comes to meat consumption
when it comes to how we heat our homes
topics that the government hasn't wanted
to touch yet but of course
businesses will also be wary to touch
them because it's not very popular to
say to your
consumer some of whom will have been
with you for decades that
you're going to hike their prices yeah
and this has got to be
talked about i mean we are coming into i
think a very difficult period for
for british politics on this issue
because
we have had almost nothing from the
government on this issue of costs
so i mean i can give you and i will give
you the um you know the
the aggregate story for the for the
economy which is which is very clear
that as we've seen the cost fall
of the alternative energy technologies
that we've talked about particularly
from renewables
we can look forward more and more to a
very low cost transition to net zero
it's actually
cost beneficial in some areas to move
away now from fossil
fuel uh technologies so most notably in
the in the transport sector when we look
at the cars and vans on our roads
very quickly in the next couple of years
potentially we will reach a price
tipping point where it's actually
cheaper
uh to own and run uh an electric car or
electric van then it is a fossil fueled
one
so that kind of saving is there but
there is no doubt
that there is real cost in some areas of
this transition
and unfortunately for for for our
politicians at least
they've fallen those costs fall in some
pretty sensitive areas
so you know the cost of heating
decarbonization so
the carbonizing homes and buildings
offices buildings
buildings across the uk that is a real
cost it's going to be it's going to be
have to be supported in some way by the
exchequer
but we've had nothing at all from the
government and what their outlook on
that is
and then the other area that is a a
major cost driver is the cost of
industry decarbonization itself
so there are industries who if we ask
them to shoulder the cost of
decarbonization it will make them
it will it will damage the
competitiveness so again that is an
issue that we need
the government to pay attention to so
standing back from this
and it's important to do that the kind
of costs that we're talking about now
are less than one percent of gdp
in every year of the transition to net
zero now actually closer to zero
in our central assessment and that's
underneath that is that story that i've
just talked about where you have
savings in some area areas and some real
costs in other areas
so there is a challenge here for the
chancellor to pick up
to capture some of the savings from
especially that surface transport
transition that i've talked about
to use that to pay for the costs in
other areas is an aggregate challenge
that really we only
have the treasury and the treasury
really needs to own that as a topic
but beneath that challenge there is a
kind of more real sense about
where we draw the line between those
consumers
be they businesses or individuals that
can afford to pay for some of this and
those that can't
and again that is an area where the
treasury has said almost nothing
so i i do look to the treasury because i
think a lot of this will need to be
supported with fiscal policies
a lot of it though can be driven with uh
solid commitments and regulations
and they tend to be the kind of things
that drive a pro-market response the
innovation
that we need the cost will fall so again
a strategy for all this would really
help
which was the point we were trying to
make last week that we are now suffering
i think
from the lack of that coherence strategy
from the government it's fine to have
the climate change committee
spell out how we think the transition
should look but we are here to give
advice we're not
we're not a regulator we don't set
policies directly so
it's time for the government to um to
come up with something that looks more
coherent
tom the best case scenario and there are
certainly reasons to be hopeful
is that costs do fall and that thing you
know um
assets like electric vehicles do become
affordable for for your average
consumer but then they're also the tough
choices when it comes to behavior that
are really difficult to sell
as well the decision for example to cut
back even slightly on the amount of meat
that one
might eat or to fly slightly less to to
change your lifestyle
um that that's a conversation again that
you know businesses and government don't
really want to have and
um nobody it seems very often apart from
chris is
is highlighting this to people as we
talk about the trade-offs of trying to
meet
these targets because as a business you
know very often you're trying to get
people to consume more
it's not it's not very um business
friendly
uh in this in this scenario to try to
convince people to roll back
um i think if you look at it a lot of
research has been done on future
consumers not current consumers
and there's a very very clear shift
towards people who want to consume
better rather than consume more
and i think that's something we really
need to acknowledge um
it's a global phenomenon but it's as
alive and well in the uk as it is
anywhere
um so i think we're going to start
thinking about consumption in a
different way and there are two things
that are really important here
one is understanding what our
environmental impact is
and it might be through eating meat
versus not eating meat
which kind of meat by the way versus
something else
it might be to do with transport the
relative merits of
train versus plane um because if you
actually understand where your carbon
footprint lies you can make some smart
informed choices
it would not be completely unrealistic
to say
somebody very close to me maybe some
member of my family is
somewhere i have to fly to and as a
result i'm going to offset
that impact by choosing to be vegan
i mean it's the numbers add up not in
every case but the numbers could add up
so you can make smart choices about
where you want your environmental impact
to lie
and what we're hearing is the people who
want to consume better wrong consume
more is because better is something that
they very firmly
get anchored in just let me ask one
really simple question can anybody
remember what a car phone looks like
because interestingly this thing's come
along instead
this is very expensive by the way
compared to almost any form of car phone
or any other form of
transport um related
communication and yet we all love this
this is something which has changed the
way in which we as consumers live our
lives
um and there are going to be other
examples coming forward so i don't think
anybody's dodging the question around
cost
the vast majority of businesses that we
work with absolutely develop a net zero
plan on the basis that it is cost
effective
and a good business case for them
because they know that what's coming
along is going to be more efficient
it's ultimately going to be cheaper it's
going to meet consumer needs in a better
way so chris is absolutely right on all
of those
but there are some some pinch points in
terms of behaviors
and i don't think we should be afraid to
have those discussions
they're perfectly reasonable you can
shoot the vast majority of people in the
uk
are starting to look at their diet and
think about it in a different way and
there is already a significant shift
towards
um you know more of a flexitarian diet
than we would have had 10 15 years ago
so let's have that discussion
and and not be afraid of it i think
politicians sometimes look at it and
think
oh i i don't dare go here i think
they're missing the point that
a whole younger generation expects them
to go there
kate can i come in on that because it's
such an important issue
overall i firmly agree with everything
that tom has just said
but just to put some numbers around this
there is indeed a
strong benefit to changing the nation's
diet the benefit is also in form of
health improvements and interestingly
the government already has guidelines
for health that set out a much more
extreme change in diet than anything
that we would recommend so we're talking
about
cutting a fifth of meat consumption of
um
out of diets today uh over the course of
the next decade and more
now it's not necessary to do that but it
will help immensely if we do and it's
worth just understanding why that is
because firstly we have that health
improvement that i talked about secondly
it will allow us to free up agricultural
land which is actually used in
it's quite wasteful actually in terms of
the land that's necessary
to have grazing animals on it when of
course there are alternatives to what we
could do with that land so
what we're talking about is freeing up
some of that land to then do something
else
and really important connecting factor
with this and this is the point that i
make
regularly is that is to the farming
community who often feel
embattled or attacked by this and i i
desperately hope that they wouldn't
feel that way is that there is an
opportunity that comes from freeing up
that land
i'm desperate to make this point that if
we get the
the policy frameworks in the right place
if defra
as the kind of lead department for this
does the job that i hope it will
then we will start to think of carbon
itself as a crop
and this idea of storing the carbon on
that land
should be a lucrative opportunity for
british farmers so if we connect all
this together just to deal
solely with the diet issues we're
talking about a healthier diet for the
nation
probably speaking directly to consumers
in this country and saying to them
eat a little less meat but eat high
quality meat that is produced
and reared here in the uk and we're
saying to the farming community there
are a set of commercial opportunities
that at present are not available to you
as that transition takes place and again
if we don't have that strategy from the
government and the leadership from
government then it becomes a discussion
solely about
diet change which of course is is
perceived as an attack by consumers and
and i
it needs to be thought of in the round
and the last thing i'll say on this
because it comes out really strongly in
our analysis i am not proposing
taxes on meat there is that suggestion
from some
in the environmental community but it's
not come from us so this kind of
transition
can come from uh stronger signposting
information provision
uh perhaps going at the extreme to to to
better labeling on food but nothing more
than that
and tom's point about the generational
divide is a real one i think we will we
will we will make that kind of
transition
towards a healthier diet inevitably
because you can see it in the
in the um in the diet shift in the diet
in the in the type of diet that we have
if you look at older people and younger
people there's already a move towards
that flexitarian diet that tom talked
about so
i don't think this should be regarded as
uh frontline in the climate discussions
or frontline in the culture wars because
it really is a
it's the kind of transition that we're
on already
and you're discussing it as voluntary of
course which as you say is is different
to how how others are
calling for it at the moment um with
only a
a few minutes left um last question um
to everyone and scott i'll start with
you and as
companies go along this journey to
decarbonization
is it helpful or even possible to have a
standard way of comparing them to one
another
or are we still in a phase where simply
encouraging companies to do the best
that they can for their sector
where that technological advancement and
where their customers are at now
allows them to do is that perhaps the
right way to go about it
or do we really need to hunker down to
see
where companies and which companies are
pulling their weight
scott let's start with you yeah i think
it's really tricky at the moment from
what i can see to have a
standard that everybody follows one of
the things that we want to do is open up
what we're doing and share that with
other businesses if they want to
comment on it and look at it and to try
and
try and do that together but like i said
at the start i think right now it's
about
turning up and showing up to make that
impact and actually getting on with
something
um you know i think that we're about
two-thirds of the way
of what we we believe we need to do and
we've still got to work out
um another third of that so that's how
it can become
difficult and we think we'll work out
that third pretty quickly as we're
engineers by
uh by trade and and by our history but i
think it's difficult for us to have a
standard
um that's set but you do also need to
you know make sure that you have those
targets in place
um and you report those targets so
everyone can see
uh what you're doing tom
yeah i think the the challenge really is
that we're trying to make change happen
a lot quicker than we would normally
uh expect markets do deliver and the
trouble is here the market won't deliver
fast enough
to meet the needs of the planet we need
to decarbonize
far quicker than a market solution alone
would uh allow
so we need the stimulus from government
we need uh consumers who are willing
and indeed keen to engage on this but i
do think the financial community has
something to bring here
net zero by the way is pretty much a
standard approach that you can take
but it's challenging without the full
disclosure and transparency we've been
talking about
tcfd is going to be an incredibly
powerful tool
the task force for climate-related
financial disclosures applied across all
listed companies within the uk
and being used as a model for
financial disclosure globally now
is an incredibly powerful potential tool
it'll provide that transparency
it'll address many of the concerns that
we have around greenwash and to your
point around is there a standard
you can't have a standard because every
con every company essentially has to go
on its own journey
it's going to have its own challenges
it's going to need to get to a certain
point
the tcfd approach allows you to look at
what you're doing at the moment it
allows you to look at future scenarios
and incorporate that in a full
disclosure
i would argue if we had to do one thing
is mandate tcfd straight away
chris yes i i completely agree with the
tcfd point and i think it is possible to
commit to a standard of of of net zero
by by committing to the actions that the
country needs to take to get there as
well so i think that combination of tcfd
plus plus a broad statement of
commitment to net zero is important
but really important to say that that it
does depend on what sector you're in
uh you the actions that you need to take
as a corporate
to align with that transition that we've
been talking about will vary by sector
so it is important to to think carefully
about what those
those at those solutions look like
depending on what the sector is and i'll
just give a brief plug to a piece of
advice that we offered in december on
that very issue
so we looked at the role of of
businesses in delivering net zero
and we set out uh some of the actions
that could
that the corporate community could take
depending on which sector they find
themselves in so if you're at all
interested in that it's a really
accessible document you can find it on
our on our website
uh well uh tom scott and chris
uh thank you so much for joining me and
again thank you to our sponsor
v lux uh for making this possible now
please stay tuned
for our next panel in today's summit uh
green and global britain
where katie balls our deputy political
editor will be
joined by an esteemed panel to discuss
global trade
and how that feeds in to the climate
agenda but again
a big thanks to our panel i wish we
could thank you in the usual way i'm
sure
people are clapping at home do stay with
us for our next panel
coming up in 15 minutes
you